obviously i'm sure you're following the
san antonio story very closely i i'm
sure you have been following the story
closely what happened with
uh uh i want to say salvador ramos right
am i saying the last time correctly
ramos right
and video came out the other day with
cops are waiting to go in we don't have
the right tools
and that's led into all this
conversation about gun reform and you
know this one could have been saved
people from both sides have come out and
said this could have been prevented from
happening there was many mistakes that
was made from the you know
stand you know don't don't go in yet how
are you handling the conversations
that's being had right now about having
gun reform and if we could have any kind
of reform i'm curious do you like the
way we have it today or any ideas you
would have
that you would suggest any kind of
reforms from your end
well naturally the left and the forces
of pro-government that want to diminish
our freedoms are focusing on the guns
okay
and uh and i think that's completely uh
misplaced
uh you know the uh
uh i don't think gun reform
would have prevented
any of the measures
even if they confiscated guns from all
law-abiding americans
this person would have come up with some
kind of a weapon you know to kill
children uh you know uh and and maybe uh
kill even more people whether it's an
explosives or uh
uh
uh
uh you know or
you know black market firearms or a
machete
you know i think the uh
the focus needs to be more on mental
health
tucker carlson had a good uh he he ran a
tape from charles krautheimer who had
been a psychiatrist a very respected
television commentator but he originally
had been a a you know a a medical
psychiatrist and that's how he had made
his living and he made the point
that
uh
you know the problem
is the way government is handling people
who obviously have mental problems
uh you know they're not
institutionalizing them they're not
uh they're not bringing them in uh to uh
when somebody makes a threat as this
person did before they killed people
that ought to trigger bring in a person
uh you know people should report that to
the police and the police should then
take this person and have them mentally
evaluated and if this person is judged
by competent psychiatrists to be a
threat they should be kept
institutionalized
and the uh the proclivity of of of the
medical bureaucracy to just release
dangerous people has got to be reversed
as well you know uh the the bias should
be
uh that uh you know unless you are
yourself willing to maybe
uh
accept legal consequences for letting go
somebody who later kills people uh you
know uh so that so that you're not
scot-free if you're a psychiatrist and
you say okay
uh i'm letting this person out on the
streets and then you have you're not at
legal risk at all yourself
you know that's just encouraging
emptying out the psychiatric hospitals
uh you know that's the direction that we
need to be able to take the the left
wants to protect the privacy rights of
these people
more than the lives of children
you know and they would prefer to blame
the boogeyman of guns when the real
boogie man is these the small very small
percentage of of mentally ill and evil
people you know uh who are being
protected by the left basically through
privacy laws and by
high-end tying the hands of both the
police and psychiatric institutions and
putting allowing so many people of these
people
that we don't keep
institutionalized anymore because it
costs money you know and it's cheaper to
let them go off and become homeless and
become dangers to uh to society you know
it's it's the policies of the left and
you know conservatives are always
fighting on the defense of being put on
the back foot by saying uh you know over
the gun rights argument when the real
argument should be
uh you know over
a mental health policy and how do we
treat you know this this this portion of
the population
also i think uh
uh
you know
uh you we ought to be more aggressive in
protecting our children
uh you know
uh
uh you know there ought to be in every
elementary school and public school you
know an officer maybe a retired cop uh
you know uh
uh
you know armed uh or the principal
should be armed or a parent
you know
who is trained in the use of firearms
ought to be
vigilantly protecting these schools
where their own children are located uh
you know
on a on a volunteer basis uh we also
need to think about
more seriously about uh about just the
architectural security of these uh of of
these schools uh you know
uh
so many windows you know that uh and and
multiple entrances that people can get
uh that people can get into
uh you know the schools ought to be
designed with safety doors for example
once that door is secured you know you'd
need
a know
you need should need hours to get
through it you shouldn't be able to just
walk in
uh so there are a lot of practical
things we can do so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]